bienvenida frabetti con recuadros como
analizados de los resultados de estas
elecciones marcadas por pocas opciones
políticas para los ciudadanos y por una
amplia apatía
muy buenos días a todos es cierto hubo
una gran apatía en estas elecciones una
abstención de mayor al 50% por primera
vez desde que subió la revolución esto
sumado a que no hubo muchos candidatos
el consejo de guardianes el consejo de
la red quienes son los encargados de
dictaminar quienes pueden ser candidatos
o no había de milagro varios posibles
candidatos entre ellos por ejemplo el ex
presidente me di negado sin embargo
llegaron a la final más muy pocos y esto
fue lo que significó que no hubiera una
votación interesante para muchos para
los reformistas como lo llama de veras
que quienes quieren un régimen era un
poco más libre esto no era una
democracia y se abstuvieron de votar en
un principio también llamar a un bombo
en las elecciones el boicot no les
funcionó porque
también selecciones de menos los mandos
medios alcaldías asambleas y no les
convenía perder esos votos y perder esos
puestos en sus posibles victorias que
estuvieran en mandos medios es decir no
funcionar huecos pero sí alcanzó hacer
media y una gran abstención ahora el
resultado fue como dijeron ustedes un
personaje de la derecha
y justamente eso lo queríamos preguntar
a nivel interno que le espera a irán
bajo la presidencia de ebrahim raisi
recordemos que se trata de un hombre
como usted lo dice sobre el cual pesan
señalamientos por su presunto rol en la
ejecución extrajudicial de prisioneros
políticos y de la amnistía internacional
pide que se reanuden las investigaciones
en su contra
realmente es un país donde se cometen
violaciones de derechos humanos todos
los días en todo momento es un alcanzó
de los años 80 en los últimos años había
una mínima libertad que se había ganado
sobre todos los demás meditar con risa
se espera que se retorne a una contra
derecha aunque se hará más estrictas las
leyes con los que están en contra del
régimen
a que haya seguramente más
encarcelamientos y como dicen cada uno
rey dentro de su castillo y eso lo creen
en especial en algunos países del medio
oriente incluidos irán quiere decir yo
puedo hacer dentro de mis fronteras lo
que yo quiera porque yo estoy ready
fácil con esa lógica y con el
antecedente que tiene la esa esfera
las floraciones a los derechos humanos
una derecha recalcitrante una derecha
muy estricta en el film para la
aplicación de las leyes